according to the New York Times Donald
Trump's campaign staff have taken away
his Twitter privileges because he is so
erratic and self-destructive the real
news should be how did it take until
election week for Donald Trump's
campaign staff to take away his Twitter
privileges and apparently according to
the New York Times Trump is still
dictating what is sent out but hope
Hicks his spokeswoman and some other
staffers are sort of betting and editing
the tweets consider the stuff that Trump
has tweeted right recommending sex tapes
on Twitter in the middle of the night
insulting countless broadcasters as a
waste Liars unwatchable etcetera
insulting everybody on the right from
Mitt Romney to even the Conservative
Club for Growth on and on and on and
here's an example of how the Trump staff
have modified Trump's tweets here's a
trump tweet that actually went out over
the last few days okay looking at Air
Force One in Miami why is he campaigning
instead of creating jobs and fixing
Obamacare get back to work for the
American people apparently Trump
dictated that only is get back to work
but his staffer hope Hicks added get
back to work for the American people I'm
hoping Pat that there's lots of other
tweets that Trump yelled out that were
just kibosh all together cuz that's a
really is sort of innocuous in small
change given the disasters that Trump is
regularly tweeting well that one in
particular seems to suggest that Obama
campaigning isn't working right he is
working he's trying to cement his legacy
for the next four years because if
Donald Trump's elected he would undo
pretty much every executive order things
like Obamacare that he's put forward
yeah and and many of those I would argue
he's not actually going to be able to
undo but the the fact that he thinks he
could and would try to is bad enough and
the bottom line on this is how can the
guy who can't control himself on Twitter
be President of the United States do you
want the guy who can't handle social
media in the Situation Room this is
insane I'm not gonna redo my rant from
the beginning of the show of the
importance of not having Donald Trump
turn the United States into a you an
even bigger laughingstock than it was
under george w bush's tenure during
george w bush's presidency I won't redo
that but if you can't handle Twitter you
can't handle the presidency let's take a
break